I've been waiting a year to tell this
story so I just need to get it
out last year something happened to me
here in
Omaha on the last day that I was here so
I I didn't want to go around the country
and talk [__] about you guys before I
told the story in front of you
first look I I I've made it very clear
to anybody who follows me I like weird
[__] I enjoy it I like it a lot and
because I talk about it a lot it it
finds me
I and people feel free look I can't tell
you how many people on the street have
walked up to me with their phone and
been like how about that I'm like wish
you'd warned me about that one
okay I don't need that is not
good and so last year in Omaha guys I am
walking downtown Saturday afternoon
beautiful day I can't I was here around
this time last year it's beautiful here
right now
and I'm walking and I just hear
Jos
J and I turn around and there's a woman
like three Three City
Blocks just waving me legit like Forest
gum and I was like
Hey and
uh she goes wait right there and she
starts sprinting towards me and I was
like I was just getting a little Head
Start just in case you know what I mean
like and she starts to scream I like
weird
sh I like weird
sh and I
stop and I'm
like all right I'm going to hang out for
this
one but look if you're going to Sprint
Three City Blocks to see me I mean I can
at least be gentleman enough to wait for
you do you know what I mean like so
she's
[__] now look I didn't get a look at
a lot of you as you walked in but I
don't know when the last time any of you
has
sprinted I mean I I know maybe past the
age of seven how many times I sprinted
on [__] one hand you know Sprint like
if you haven't sprinted in a while it's
it's not easy and to Sprint Three City
Blocks I'm waiting for her and she gets
to me and she does
[Laughter]
this and I'm like you're good you're
good she goes
yeah and then she
goes I don't run that
much
I go yeah yeah take your time no big
deal and you could see she was starting
to get embarrassed by how heavy she was
breathing and that she couldn't catch
her breath and she started to get
anxious and
hyperventilate and so she was really
right
really and there was such crazy violent
breathing happening that she did that
she like did that hi snort burp thing
where where you know what it's like and
you're like what the
[__] it was such
a I was like oh okay and she was so
embarrassed that she was
like she couldn't get herself and I was
like oh no no no no no and she
just threw up oh it gets so much worse
all
right she throws up man but there's two
ways that people throw up you can throw
up and be like and it just kind of you
know or you can [__] power wash the
sidewalk
like that's what she did
she and and guys hey we're Downtown
Omaha on a beautiful Saturday there's
people in these streets you know what I
mean and this dude is just walking with
his son right past
us six-year-old kid maybe and
shorts and when
she it's she's hitting the ground so
hard
it's and she gets it all over this kid's
leg and the dad if you have kids you've
done this before you know where you you
do the swing to get him out of
danger you know that swing and by the
way way Midway in that swing you're
always like I hope the wrist makes it
you know what I mean
like there's that one part you're like
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay
has that been happening the whole
[Applause]
show cuz I was like did a bird just fly
into the
[Laughter]
room listen I can't say [__] about the
way people laugh you've heard me laugh
before holy
[__]
but he swings his kid man and Y the kid
had puke all over it
fresh so it was still Loosey Goosey on
there you
know so when he swung him it flew off
his leg back into
her and
she I was I couldn't believe what I was
watching
honestly so I sitting there and she's so
embarrassed she's like oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my God like it's okay
it's okay totally
okay and then I was like
well thanks a lot
[Applause]
uh I feel like we're pretty much done
here
I and she
said wait wait wait don't you want to
see the weird [__] and I was like
weirder than you throwing up on a
stranger's
leg Yeah I was like Hey you're not going
to top that uh we're good we're good